c'est ce convoyage en voyant aient
l'impression de te
bussières maigret
en face nous a conté
m
la db ouais il est tellement grave
oui il avait commencé des machins de
cinéma qui s'appuie tout le monde
croyait qu'il attend les électro le
camion tout ça après on s'est rendu
compte que c'est att
[Musique]
les garçons à l'école
[Applaudissements]
chaque fois ça se termine avant ce jour
puisque nous allons salle aura un gars
vaud vient de partir de dole et on va ça
laurent en grandvaux parce que j'habite
là bas la grande rivière
je crois que c'est à cause de ce nom
c'est pas que je suis content quand elle
s'appelle grande rigueur alors je me
steve marin grandes rivières c'est un
début
ça fait vibrer le sol américain alors on
dit on dit qui vous êtes là en 30
secondes
je vous écoute oui et non non c'est vous
c'est vrai vous avez fait du cinéma
ouais il fait l'acteur oui je suis le
réalisateur ou un peu tout ça qui
perdent famille oui mais alors tout ça
c'est dans le voit tout ça en même temps
moi je n'ai en 44 dans le jura toro et
sage en chinois
[Musique]
j'aime pas vraiment un
alors je crois que c'est du truc
d'enfance tout bête le train c'était un
horaire fixe il fallait tout vérifié il
fallait pipi leur leur fixe et j'aime
pas ça puisque nos plus mauvais souvenir
de train à soffin que je dis alors la
vie de fait surtout qu'on a embarqué
dans cette gare c'est assez magique à
dole sais qu'un jour je perds un chat
j'étais encore avec une femme ma
première femme et comme on dit la
première femme est à partir d'un certain
moment ça fait drôle de dire ma première
parce qu'on lui avait parlé de sa venue
ne va peut-être pas on est en train de
s'engager sur le quai de la gare on
s'engueulait on avait un chaque été dans
un panier et le travail dans le
couinement des freins et ben
le chat se sort du panier est là sans
fil et sous le train
catastrophe moi je vais carrément je dis
tu bouges pas je descend sous le train
puis c'est quand même assez fou à
l'époque je me rends compte train quitte
à l'arrêt je me glisse ou le train en
train d'essayer de récupérer greffiers
qui me voyaient il bougeait pas et ils
voulaient pas venir au bout d'un moment
alors sur sortie parce que les mecs
m'ont dit oh bon et ils ont fait un truc
incroyable genre film à gabat sur la
résistance et où ils m'ont sorti le
train ils ont été les thèmes et chemine
comme ça ils ont été maîtres le train
sur la fausse d'inspection ils ont
cherché le chat qui n'ont pas trouvé le
greffier l'été jusqu'à dix ans après
avec quelqu'un l'a trouvée là-bas parce
qu'ils violaient ils étaient couverts de
trucs ils ont foutu dans la cabine qui
rentre à paris
hélas ma femme
le prix sera moi la voiture est déjà le
couple en pleine forme
[Rires]
est ce que vous êtes aimé des femmes
sachez pas trop sans blague
ah non non non parce que je suis pas
trop dragueur alors
par contre il ya des vrais copains qui
dit mais tu te rends pas compte mais
l'âme et écoute dans cette voie pas moi
j'ai passé tellement d'années ça
commençait d'ailleurs dans le jura lé
tous les petits bas de tout son attrait
nas et regarder les filles comme ça
avoir des copains lors par contre où les
filles se jeter dessus et moi j'étais
comme un nasa côté justin mais qu'est ce
qui se passe par celle c'est troublant
bien
le siège de diversion
tout y est joli garçon
comme ap jimmy aller comme la cause de
james dean la photo jim singh avait la
tronche à james dean avec les cheveux
comme ça j'aurais dû y croire plutôt des
airs pire
deux dates en 25 ans ont commencé les
histoires dessinées majorité commencent
et c'est justement pas confiance à cause
des saloperies de gonzesses comme dirait
finale aller qu'est ce que vous en fais
rien justement il ne faisait rien moi je
sais rien mais vraiment un vrai tombeur
1 espèce de coup du regard 43 wisla qui
marcha symbole non pas du tout non non
non non tu règles domaine domaine
non mr dès lors par exemple aussi les
grandes histoires d'amour
il ya une chose bizarre qui se passe on
est dans une époque en réalité il ya le
fléau mais c'est pire que le sida c'est
la conjugale riz caisse et ça l'a
conjugale ring c'est que
les hommes n'y vont pas avec les femmes
les couples sont foutus rien ne va et ça
c'est 99 et demi pour cent il ya john
cassavettes en amérique a fait des films
là dessus mes enfants c'est
extraordinaire jeudi les enfants qui
vont à l'école 80% les parents sont
divorcés
c'est maintenant la règle absolue alors
qu'il ya 10 15 ans non au contraire fils
divorce est déjà un peu bizarre
maintenant il est le grand coup de balai
68 le grand coup de temps son soi-disant
de libération mais 2 me choque tout ça a
été de tout ça c'est les cas ou
historiques comme mais ce qui fait que
maintenant il ya plus deux
je passe plus grand chose là
vous regrettez sa rando en vélo entre
l'eau voilà dieu m'a répondu
ce mercato
c'est parce que c'est noël
[Musique]
la messe de minuit c'est un moment quand
même très très magique puis on sortait
la messe de minuit on allait faire 25
bornes appuyé je dis ça parce que vous
êtes une marcheuse et que c'était notre
grand plaisir de passer une nuit blanche
déjà c'était lady blanche qui commençait
c'est à dire que la soigner tout ça
ouais à périgny jura montaigu conliège
tout tout le revermont comme ça c'est à
dire sortie de la messe de minuit et le
grand trajet jusqu'à lokua marché la
nina city noël magique qui t'as quel âge
c'était quand j'avais 10 ans
s'accommoder de 10 à 16 18
après ça devient un peu triste noël
[Applaudissements]
premiers souvenirs d'enfance quelque
part dans les ardennes
e
j'ai une arrière-grand-mère il y avait
un escalier qui partait de là que je
connaissais pas bien je devais avoir
trois ans ça je me souviens parce que je
vais comme j'y fus avait pas beaucoup là
bas je penchais ma tête on fera pareil
chez moi de tanner il y avait un peu à
la traîne chez mini s qui m'émerveille s
de jeu
repérez qu'on voyait le ciel quoi c'est
à dire on se mettait la tête y avait pas
de feuille je me ferai peut-être
intérieur est tout en haut on voyait le
ciel qui déboucha passé grand conduit
noir et comme il ya des repères assez
précis ça doit être un des premiers
souvenirs d'enfance a pris un petit
escalier avec un truc en x pour couper
le bois est une espèce de table en 2001
comme ça calé contre une fenêtre
j'avais marié à craon berck au sol
c'était d'appeler trois invasion et à la
dernière fois le 10 et 15 de 70 14 et 40
et l'habitait ouvre à des ardennes et de
la belgique
chaque fois que l'allemagne repassait et
c'était tout droit s'est elle doit de
gants de la meuse qu'on appelle c'était
vraiment non il avait commandant dont la
poste l'empaillage même pas besoin de
les piquer ça marchait toujours la
dernière fois en 40
une fois alors la grosse des balles
parce que là on a pris une bonne
torchonné des bacs machin et l'a fait 15
km avec tous les réfugiés pire elodie
gens de chez moi ils m'ont bien il est
rentré puis s'est rien passé
on disait les russes violent tout le
monde armée allemande julia une vache
qui étaient tués par un bombardement
mais les rester là
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
oui
enfin à l'idée là quand j'étais à lons
le saunier jura avec l'icann à ce que
j'en fais mal bidabé tous les défauts et
tout
j'ai approché alors que je te mets pas
raconter ça
mais c'est un trajet d'énergie qui m'a
tout apporté
mais transfère toute l'année
moi très femme c'est à dire que je vais
en mobylette voir des concerts a besoin
km
en cas pas la mettre en confiance
maintenant j'ai la grosse moto j'y vais
éviter la wii c'est vrai c'est que ça
lui fait la clientèle n'a pas grand
chose mais
c'est pas moi c'est sûr très laid mais
roche ne doit jouer
ouais et vous avez mettre au caire oui
dans la prochaine du shock and awe la
santé sans discuter qu'un truc simple
rock tu as ton machin tu arrives tu
donnes les gens hypnotique à la fnac six
mois d'avancé a plus de place les
merguez
pip en faut donner donne en mille 15 mai
dans ses droits quel rôle pas du tout
mais non mais je suis moi je voulais de
chanteurs danse pas je suis là depuis
tout petit je pensais que j'avais plus
draguer une fille puisque dans sport
[Musique]
le virer il ya passé je crois en année
réel quatre ans dans la place où je lui
rappelle ouais déjà qu'ils arrivaient
des machins il vient à lorient mène tout
un tas de gens gens vont s'arrêtent
boire un coup chez un original machin
mais seulement lui il a réussi il
débranche les plombs et reste quatre
jours et dans les gars ou d'un moment
comment on fait pour la bouffe l'hôtel
templiers ont fait que d'or walo et sa
veste et il restait donc cinq ans
j'exagère mais plus d'un an et les mêmes
qui disent bon jacques ben moi je suis
très bien que peu pourquoi elle fait
comme en bas ils se pressent pas l
époque bénie n'est pas pressés nous le
trajet qu'il faut pour venir ici
comment ça st il a mené le mec de
l'étang bond de 6,6 mais peut-être mais
comment t'es tu gaspilles à elle le
chien ainsi qu'elle s'était nakheel fine
celle qui était disparu pilou là bas
c'est celui-là des tampons de la plus
jeune et la zone est donc plus d'un coup
il ne fait plus plaisir c'est qu'un
jouet fait un petit bain tu as fait ça
1-1 et aurait elle un petit mâle l'a
toujours
un petit baume et comment ça t'est venue
l'idée sa belle pour me tanguay sur
scène elle s'en sert les événements
puis fait des surprises comme ça fait un
petit banc s'est jamais plus ardemment
samba était rose au champagne
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire quand
elle dit jean-françois cet os qu'il faut
qu'il réponde
si la main il appelle chez lui et chez
lui à 15 ans alors
elle joue avec la diligence oui un
simple j'ai parlé du loup en deux
saisons
y'a pas besoin de marguerite duras si j
ai
et aurait été bon on attend l'amour 1
c'est encore autre chose l'amour qu'ils
ne viennent pas mais c'est pas de
l'amour qui entre vous un jour il m'a
parlé de platonique maître du mois qui a
fait une bande de nazes qui rigolaient
autour l'eau qui m'a dit je préfère
l'amour platonique et hindi bah oui
parce qu'on touche j'utilise yeux il
volé un pain sec et que vous en pensez
quoi
oui je pense ya des rencontres des
frôlements comme vous vous croyez faire
une interview plus à ressortir de là il
va faire lui fait moins 30 puis l'a19
indien ap 2-3 ici
[Musique]
oui
suite à
l'un des rares françaises jurassien de
cinéma qui adore de loin à la presse qu
est ce que vous les trouvez on a un
comportement on parlait du travail tout
à l'heure c'est vraiment des gens qui
sont possédés par une très très mauvaise
réputation
si l'on regarde du corps lunettes noires
extrême droite machin pitt dans le
goulot juste au moment du travail pas
une heure avant une chaleur qui bat
c'est le seul qui m'ait filet ça moi qui
suis tellement copains du gros depardieu
et sans blague c'est moi je m'attendais
à tout sauf
c'est très impressionnant de trafic des
gens tous types sans mal du fait d'un
seul coup un vrai contact un vrai truc
pour le boulot hein
dix minutes après fini thirga avec tout
le monde pareil les parties talkie
walkie à la main au cul et une fois je
revois d'ailleurs je suis tellement
midinettes moi dans ma tête je veux une
fausse studio je vois des mecs qui
disent que tu as vu de ton copain de
longue haleine qu'il a il vit de cinéma
lui il habite un studio à paris où il a
son bureau alors qu'il a une île au
japon et tout ce qu'on veut ils habitent
là lui parce qu'il a besoin de l'odeur
des machins tout le monde l'a entendu
attendiez de l'anc et révèle alors moi
je le regarde a servi à voile allen de
lundi d'or est comme ça comme nous ils
regardent la khl à toi tranquille talent
aussi bien dans jurassien comment tu
veux bon ça c'est un petit truc tu vois
tu que moi j'aurais complètement admis
que l'autre passe devant puis c'est pas
parce que c'est de là mais c'est un
rapport évident seul coup tu sens un
vrai machin et ça sert à ressentir des
vins machin alors quand on sent un vrai
tu dis tiens commencer ce combat c'est
tombé sur lui comment je fais mon faible
suivi entre les deux là car des objets
alors ça ces objets vivent à 1 e et
trois dans l'arbre l'aube à la petite
et puis comme milliards jeu racheter une
boîte de peinture disons faire gare
d'allan l'appétit
voilà c'est la maison c'est une maison
c'est le soleil c'est l'os et l'amour
c'est tout quand tu vois c'est un petit
dessin ses voitures robinson ayant peur
qu'on me prenne le temps d'antenne
immédiatement alors les remplaçants je
dois avouer n'ont rien truc devrait
c'est je sais pas pourquoi c'est un noir
qui fait du karaté enfin sonné c'est par
noir c'est georges ah bon il fait un an
qu'on guérit faute et yoko guérissent
aux thèses et une position pièce est
parfaite c'est le coutier broustic
sauter ça et puis comme j'étais en train
de décoller il ya encore les chatterton
là tout de suite là pour les besoins de
la télévision je me suis décrocher ça
parce que c'est la seule qui subsiste
est quand même
alors alors
marilyn monroe la guerre et surtout
l'autre la monty clift et c'est vrai que
moi quand j'étais en forme en ce truc là
puisqu'il s'agit d'eux que je parlais un
peu de moi quand même bien que ce soit
difficile c'est vrai que la grande
récompense de toute la vie c'était des
caves et un truc extraordinaire choix
d'aller au cinéma
et moi j'ai vu comme ça les misfits
voilà quoi que ça continue voilà bien on
va pas tarder à aller marcher mais les
manceaux vous connaissez les stars
d'achille
achille oui mes talons oui c'est quoi un
talon d'achille
ces enfants
[Musique]